قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
صدتها هجمات روسيه مركزه في جبهه كميونك
شرقا حيث تحاول القوات الروسيه التقدم
باتجاهها منذ اسابيع واكدت الهيئه ان
الجيش الاوكراني واصل هجماته باستخدام
المروحيات والطائرات باتجاه مدينه توبل من
محاور عده في الجبهه الجنوبيه في زبيروجيا
واشارت الهيئه الى ان القوات الروسيه قصفت
المواقع والقوات الاوكرانيه لمنع اي تقدم
باتجاه عمق دفاعاتها
من جهه اخرى اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
احباط محاوله هجوم اوكرانيه على اراضي
مقاطعه وفي مقاطعه كورسكا الروسيه
المحاديه لاوكرانيا اعلنت السلطات اصابه
سيده بجروح نتيجه قصف اوكراني لقريه في
المقاطعه وقال حاكم مقاطعه كورسكو في
حسابه على تيليجرام ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت البلده ثلاث مرات في الساعات
الاخيره بدورها اعلنت سلطات مقاطعه
بريانسك تعرض قريتين لقصف اوكراني الحق
اضرارا محدوده ببعض البيوت
في واشنطن قال منسق والاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جونكر بان واشنطن لا تشجع اي
ضربات عسكريه داخل روسيا واضاف في احاطه
ان من الملاحظ ان القوات الاوكرانيه حققت
تقدما خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه واكد
انه يتوقع ان ترد روسيا على هذا التقدم
الاخير